الطرق المزدحمة والمطارات المزدحمة والكثير من
العطلات المجهدة سيكون المسافرون 2022 هو
الأعلى منذ 2018 و 2019 ولكن
ليس بنفس الارتفاع مع توقع AAA أن يسافر ما يقرب من
113 مليون شخص 50 ميلاً
أو أكثر من 23 ديسمبر إلى 2 يناير ،
إليك بعض النصائح من
خبراء السفر  لجعل رحلتك أكثر سلاسة
وتجنب معظم الفوضى إذا كنت تطير ،
توقع حشودًا أكبر تقول AAA أن السفر الجوي
سيشهد زيادة بنسبة 14 مقارنة بالعام الماضي
، أول نصيحة تجنب فحص الحقيبة حاول
إحضار حقيبة يد فقط إذا
تم إلغاء رحلتك أو  إذا فاتتك اتصال ،
فمن الأسهل بكثير أن تصعد على
متن طائرة جديدة وأن تكون ذكيًا إذا لم يكن لديك
حقيبة مسجلة ، وعليهم أن يذهبوا للعثور على
النصيحة الثانية إذا كان عليك فحص
الحقيبة ، فإليك بعض النصائح لتجنب
فقدها  تسمح لك الكثير من شركات الطيران بتتبع
أمتعتك التي تم فحصها على تطبيقها ، ولكن
إليك نصيحة أخرى رقم ثلاثة ،
خذ متتبعًا مثل Apple Air
Attack مرة أخرى وقم بإسقاطه في حقيبتك
لتتبع رحلته ، إنها واحدة من أفضل
النصائح e  مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
عدد تعطل الرحلات
وعدد الحقائب التي تم إساءة استخدامها والنصيحة الرابعة إذا
كنت تنطلق على الطريق ،
توصي شركة Triple A بتجنب هذه الأيام الأكثر ازدحامًا
يوم الجمعة قبل عيد الميلاد والعودة إلى
المنزل في 27 و 28 ديسمبر منذ
كل من عطلات عيد الميلاد والجديد.
سيكون خريف العام في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع هذا العام ،
ثم الجمعة قبل عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، سيكون
يومًا مزدحمًا بالسفر بالنسبة لساعة المستهلك اليوم ،
أنا جين سوليفان